おはよ
ﾜｧｰｯwwﾋｨｰｯwwﾋｨｰｯwwﾋｨｰｯwwﾋｨｰｯww
あのー僕かな～り昔に
っていうめっちゃくちゃでっけぇゴキブリで
ドッキリしたことあるんですけどもォ
うわぁー・・・ほんっとに無理・・・
やば
ﾌｯww
ｳﾜｯww
最近、
って思いまして
やっぱ、あの責任もって飼うことが
僕たぶんできないと思ったんでｪ
いかにリアルで
巨大なトカゲが
売ってねェかと思って調べたところ・・・！
モザイク　解除ｯ！！
\ ぼぎゃーん /
いやぁ～これやばいのは俺
イグアナは好きなんですけど
トカゲがあんまり得意じゃないんですよね
（懺悔の自傷）
なんでこれ、どうやって作ったｧ？
うぅｯわァア↑ァ↑
俺さァ～～
爬虫類いいんだけどね？
しっぽが苦手なんスよね
だってもうさ
しっぽリアルすぎん？これ
うわぁ待って
なんかこのヘンなこのバウンド感が
スゴいリアル
うわ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”！！
ｯﾋｬｯ↑
”ウ”ウ”オ”ゥェ”
ﾊｧｰ･･･
ｧウｯ”あ”あ”あーｯ
まってほんとにやヴぁい
ｳ"-↓
待ってぇおなかの
ぶにぶに感
とかリアルだったらすごい嫌だなー・・・
\　ぶよーん　/
う”わぁあ～
こ　　わ　　い
う”わぁ”！
ﾋｨｯ↑
ﾋｨｯ↑↑
ﾋｨｯ↑↑↑
いやもう慣れるしかねェ
もう触ってなれるしかねェ
いや結局
もう慣れるしかないんだよ
俺が慣れるしかない
俺は爬虫るい～の慣れ方を
俺が爬虫類（！？）
知ってんだよ
もうね･･触って慣れるしかないんだよ
もうねほら
URYYYYY!?
めっちゃリアルなんスよ
顔はねぇそんなちょっと･･･
まぁまぁちょっと
”作った感”があるんですけど
体のディティールがもう
足とか･･･やばいじゃん！
手もマジでねぇ　ほ　ぽいんスよ
からだの柔らかさとか本物じゃんもう
俺コレさわったことあるから
分かるんスよねェ～～
ううううううッわ
(ｽﾊﾟｧン)
バウゥンド感･･･なんだろ･･･
すごい･･･
こｫ～～～～れは･･･
パッと居たら間違いなく
本物と見間違うでしょう
動物園で見たときの
巨大トカゲもこれぐらいのサイズ感
だったんで･･･もう
大きさ！！
ディティール！！
からだの柔らかさ！！
全てにおいてかなり！本物に近いと
思います。
僕本物さわったし、見たんで、
僕の記憶が正しければ
マジですごいですコレ
というわけで今日はァ？
巨大トカゲを使って
ドッキリしていこうと思います。
もう慣れた･･･
もう慣れた、オレはもう慣れたよ
いや、ホントは飼いたいんだよ?
こうゆう子がさ
のそのそ
こうやって歩いたらすごいかわいいじゃん。
慣れたr･･･
う”グロｫｯ！！
というわけで今ァ
朝の、７時１５分、
何故私がこんな
時間まで徹夜で起きていたかといいますと、
というわけで今ァ
上にターゲットがぐっすり
寝ているので、
その幸せ感をちょっと見ていこうと思います
では行こうｯ！！
(電気つける音)
\　にょーん　/
\ pon /
キャー///
うぅわｯ(頭蓋骨
うぅわｯ(背骨
うぅわｯ(膝
うぅわｯ(小指
たぶん後ろの方がリアルなんで、
しっぽを向けておいておきます・・・
(城之内　克也)
おはよ
お～おぉ～おーお～おぉ～(嬉しい
珍しいな。
けっ･･･こーびっくりしましたww
ww結構じゃねーじゃんｗ
オレｪ～
俺～のあれにびっくりしましたｗ
でしょォ？W
\ POOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOON /
えっ
ﾍﾍwﾍｯﾍww
ﾍﾍﾍｯw
何？w
何、カメラ回ってないのに･･･ｗ
何ｗ何ｗ
\ pon /
いや、そんなことやってない
そぉんな･･･入れてないから！ｗ
何？
ちょ、待って
そんなことある？
何？？
回ってないん･･
はふは
ﾝｯﾌｯﾌｯww
ｱ"ﾊｯﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊw